[Música]
quiero invitarlos a que como cierre de
este evento exponencial nos demos el
lujo de hacer un viaje y en este viaje
los que se sientan cómodos ahí donde
están sentados pueden cerrar los ojos y
no lo sabrán hasta que les indique lo
contrario
ahí donde están con los ojos cerrados
quiero que respiren profundamente
quiero que vean justo al frente una
ventana moderadamente grande esta
ventana es luminosa
es blanca y está abierta vamos a
traspasar esa ventana ahí donde están
sentados y moviéndose a través de esta
ventana van a salir del otro lado en el
año 2025 en este año 2025 suceden muchas
cosas vean a su alrededor
como se ve el cielo
hay objetos en este cielo naturales o
artificiales quiero que vean a su
alrededor
a edificios hay naturaleza
ambas ninguna
y quiero que busquen si existen otras
personas a su alrededor en el año 2025 a
través de esta ventana que acabamos de
traspasar cómo se ven los humanos
se dan cuenta que al frente hay otra
ventana aún más grande más luminosa y
más abierta por supuesto que vamos a
traspasar esa otra ventana también
y del otro lado ahora estamos en el año
en este año 2050 que hay en el cielo
vean a su alrededor de una vuelta 360
edificios árboles busquen personas
busquen cualquier objeto que se mueva
como se ve en esos objetos
ahora van a ir a su bolsillo izquierdo y
van a sacar de ahí un espejo van a
colocar ese espejo frente a ustedes y
quiero que vean su rostro
cómo se ve su rostro en el año 2050 se
ve similar a como se ve en el año 2019 o
se ve dramáticamente diferente
pongamos de vuelta el bolsillo en el
espejo en el bolsillo izquierdo nos
volvemos y vamos a traspasar esa primer
ventana
ahora estamos de vuelta en el año 2025
damos otra vuelta alrededor para ver si
nos quedó algo que no habíamos visto
y ahora vamos a traspasar la primera
ventana que pasamos la del año hasta el
2019 y una vez de vuelta en el 2019 y
ahí donde están en cuando se sientan
cómodos quiero que abran los ojos
como se veía es el futuro
en sus mentes como se imaginaron el año
2025 cuando vamos a hacer casi 8 mil
millones de personas cohabitando en el
planeta pero tal vez lo más interesante
es cómo se ve el año 2050 cuando seremos
casi 11.000 millones de personas
cohabitando en el planeta
la realidad
es que nadie sabe cómo se va a ver ese
futuro
lo que sí sabemos
es que en este futuro vamos a tener
los problemas más grandes que hemos
enfrentado como humanidad
vamos a estar viviendo época de
transición cambio climático
inestabilidad social económica y
financiera
la posibilidad de aumentar nuestras
capacidades humanas hasta el punto de
que dejen de ser naturales y nos
convirtamos cada vez más en seres
artificiales
en este futuro
sabemos que vamos a vernos enfrentados a
retos ambiciosos que van a necesitar
soluciones innovadoras las más
innovadoras que hayamos creado como
humanidad y la única forma para llegar a
esto es a través de aprendizaje
exponencial
lo que sí sabemos es que el mundo en el
que estamos viviendo el año 2019 nunca
hemos vivido una tasa de aceleración tan
rápida como la de este año y por otro
lado nunca va a ser tan lenta como en
este momento voy a decirlo nuevamente
este año es el más rápido que hemos
experimentado como humanidad y al mismo
tiempo va a ser lo más lento que vamos a
vivir a partir de este momento
algunas personas consideran que el
futuro del trabajo se ve así máquinas
desplazando a las personas
yo quisiera invitarlos a que durante los
próximos cinco minutos siete minutos
pensemos en otra alternativa en una
alternativa en donde más bien nuestras
capacidades son aumentadas gracias a esa
ciencia y a esta tecnología y para esto
vamos a hacer un pequeño recorrido de
por qué razón esto puede aumentar
nuestras capacidades en vez de dejarnos
desplazados si tuviéramos que decirle a
este grupo de niños ya su ex ministro
que tenían que estudiar para poder ser
relevantes en 30 años que le diríamos
posiblemente algunas personas dirán
programación que aprendan habilidades
técnicas todo eso estoy totalmente de
acuerdo y no voy a repetir un poco lo
que mis compañeros también han
mencionado durante la mañana
la realidad es
y nadie sabe
nadie tiene la más remota idea de cómo
se van a ver los trabajos en 30 años
siete de cada diez chiquitos que estaban
en esa fotografía siete de cada diez
niños que empezaron primer grado este
año van a terminar trabajando en empleos
que ni siquiera existen o sea van a
tener que inventarse sus trabajos como
se supone que les vayamos a decir que
estudiar
pero lo más importante y relevante en
este momento
es quien le decimos a la gente que está
haciendo hoy desplazada por tecnología y
no estamos hablando de cómo ser
relevantes en 30 años qué tal cómo ser
relevantes en tres años
estamos acostumbrados biológicamente
codificados a pensar de forma lineal
entonces vamos a explorar un poco que
significa pensamiento lineal versus
pensamiento exponencial pensamiento
lineal significa de que yo soy esta
caricatura acá empecé el colegio me
enrolé en la universidad y pensaba que
con un pedazo de papel iba a poder
trabajar el resto de mi vida y esta
primera línea punteada me iba a llegar a
donde yo quería que me llevara en el
futuro pero claramente así no es como
funciona el mundo ni la vida hay un
aspecto un factor sorpresa de
crecimiento exponencial que me cambia
totalmente el panorama que me hace tener
que tomar decisiones distintas a mi plan
original y esas decisiones distintas me
llevan en una curva exponencial
en donde realmente es donde terminó
acabando en ese futuro jamás me lo pude
haber imaginado es como pensar por
ejemplo que la carrera que inicie cuando
tenía 18 o 19 años es con la que me voy
a retirar a los 65 por cierto espero que
todos estemos claros de que nadie va a
recibir una pensión cuando cumpla 65
años
esta curva exponencial es la que sigue
la tecnología y la sigue muy bien es
cien por ciento de las probabilidades de
que todas las tecnologías y ciencias
sigan esta curva tienen un inicio lento
al principio pensamos que las
tecnologías no van a funcionar muy bien
porque claramente están apenas en etapa
de desarrollo pero luego llegan a un
punto de aceleración que los permite
llegar a una singularidad singularidad
significa que llegan a tener desempeños
muchísimo más exitosos en promedio que
el promedio humano entonces para decirlo
en términos prácticos empieza en
patineta y en algún momento se convierte
en un cohete espacial para llegar hasta
la luna
la línea rosada sobre nosotros
a partir de este momento quiero que
consideren que aspectos de su vida están
viviendo desde un lugar lineal que
deberían estar transición 'no hacia un
lugar exponencial porque el mundo ya no
es lineal
veámoslo con un ejemplo práctico si yo
les digo que voy a dar 30 pasos y cada
paso que yo dé es de un metro entonces
después de 30 pasos hacia dónde voy a
llegar 30 metros cierto
cada paso de 1 metro 30 pasos hacia
adelante son 30 metros a eso le
podríamos conocer como un paso lineal
pero qué pasa si voy a dar 30 pasos
exponenciales en donde cada paso que yo
dé va a duplicar el anterior
primero voy a dar 1 y luego 2 luego me
va a llevar a 4 y así consecuentemente
después de 30 pasos exponenciales qué
tan lejos voy a haber llegado alguien
super bueno en mate
me lleva a dar 26 vueltas alrededor de
la tierra
todas las decisiones que tomemos a
partir de ese momento podríamos estar
tomando las basadas en un concepto
exponencial que cada paso que demos vaya
a duplicar los resultados y el esfuerzo
que el paso anterior
no podemos resolver problemas pensando
de la misma forma que cuando los creamos
alguna persona muy inteligente dijo eso
en algún momento
entonces lo que sea que hemos hecho
hasta hoy la tecnología lo va a hacer
mejor por ejemplo con la robótica cuando
yo estaba creciendo esta era la idea de
robótica que yo tenía una caricatura que
salía esto tal vez pueda revelar mi edad
pero
quienes se acuerdan de esta caricatura
por favor acompáñenme gracias la mitad
del evento
esta caricatura es de su personaje que
se llama rutina era la asistente
robótica de una familia que se llamaba
supersónicos y rutina les hacía todo yo
pensaba que así iban a hacer los robots
en el futuro y me quedé como esperando
en el 2015 veo este vídeo de la
competencia más grande de robótica en el
mundo en donde las mayores empresas de
desarrollo ponían a sus mejores robots a
competir qué es esto
cómo puede ser que esto sea lo mejor que
la ciencia y la tecnología puede ofrecer
ni siquiera pueden tomar pasos bien esto
fue en el 2015 pueden buscarlo es
chistosísimo y tan solo tan solo tres
años después esto sucedió
este es a placer el robot de boston
dynamics y atlas hace parkour
haz de parkour mejor que el promedio
humano
en tan solo tres años pasando de ni
siquiera poder dar un paso o abrir una
puerta a hacer parkour me hace pensar de
que la tecnología si está
desarrollándose de manera exponencial
cuántas nuevas habilidades aprendimos en
tres años
con inteligencia artificial y la
combinación de robótica también podemos
llegar a un sinfín de posibilidades
de esta fotografía cual dirían que es el
humano y cuál dirían que es la máquina
ok entonces la de la izquierda parece
ser más o menos artificial la de la
derecha parece ser humana está bien voy
a decirles que están en lo correcto la
persona de la derecha se llama la
doctora susan wilder ella tiene una
empresa que se llama zhang wei y hay en
century básicamente ahí lo dice están
desarrollando ciencia y tecnología para
crear seres artificiales súper empáticos
están tratando de replicar la empatía
humana en una máquina y esa es la misión
de vida de la doctora susan que el
derecho
qué va a pasar con el mundo y con la
industria de servicio al cliente
si tenemos seres digitales super
empáticos de nuevo no vamos a abrir la
discusión si es empatía real o es
empatía ficticia lo único que
necesitamos es que nos haga pensar que
es realmente si son empáticos
o qué va a pasar con básicamente
cualquier profesión cuando podamos tener
la posibilidad de insertar un chip en
nuestros cerebros y aprender nuevas
habilidades técnicas y destrezas en
cuestión de segundos suena como una
película de ciencia ficción lo sé varias
pero existen ya bastantes empresas que
están desarrollando esto neural inc es
un startup fundado por hilo en moscú un
emprendedor exitoso en sillicon valley
de tecnología y new rolling está en este
momento contratando una base de personas
de casi 500 entre ellos contadores
diseñadores ingenieros eléctricos o sea
casi que muchos de nosotros acá para
poder generar un producto de integración
cerebro humano máquina se le llaman
integraciones humano máquina y con esas
integraciones nos permite expandir
nuestras capacidades hace dos meses y lo
en moscú anunció que para el 2020 van a
lanzar su primer producto una
integración humano máquina para el ser
de personas con parálisis
la biogenética que nos puede ofrecer
también
nos ofrece la posibilidad de secuenciar
nuestro adn a principios de este siglo
en el 2001 el costo para hacer una
secuencia de un genoma era de casi 100
millones de dólares
vean cómo el precio anteriormente se ha
reducido y ahora pueden adquirir un kit
casero de secuenciamiento genético por
29 99 en ebay yo lo hice y esos fueron
mis resultados al parecer tengo 33%
menos probabilidad de tener un gato y
52% más probabilidad de ser vegetariana
son datos interesantes pero no me sirven
de nada hasta que llegamos a los datos
de salud
esos datos de salud el poder
democratizar el acceso a la información
de salud puede revolucionar la industria
médica y lo está haciendo pero qué va a
pasar con todas las personas que no
tengan acceso a este tipo de
herramientas se quedarán rezagados en un
sistema obsoleto cómo hacemos para
levantar y que el progreso y la
abundancia vengan para todos
la biogenética también nos permite
alterar modificar los alimentos hay
11.000 hay recursos en este planeta para
alimentar a 11 mil millones de personas
sin embargo mil millones de personas se
acuestan todas las noches con su
estómago vacío
la biogenética también nos permite
alterar la lonja la longevidad humana se
habla de que la persona la primera el
primer ser humano que va a vivir hasta
los mil años ya nació
y también nos permite la posibilidad de
alterar genéticamente a humanos antes de
que nazcan esto ya sucedió bueno ya está
sucediendo quienes han probado la el
whopper imposible es la hamburguesa de
famosa de berger quin hecha a base de
plantas genéticamente modificadas para
que sepan igual a la carne cada efe se
lanzó hace una semana su billón chickens
y básicamente es pollo no te puedes dar
cuenta tal vez alguien muy conocedor sí
pero la persona promedio no se daría
cuenta de que está comiendo plantas en
vez de pollo
en las primeras 5 horas de haber lanzado
este producto se quedaron sin producto
se agotó
si hay mercado para este tipo de
productos
el año pasado salió la noticia de que un
grupo de investigadores y científicos
chinos había modificado genéticamente
dos embriones de humanos para cerrar y
remover la puerta genética que permitía
que el ser humano pudiera contraer el
virus de sida
ya existen personas vivas que han sido
modificadas genéticamente que en teoría
no van a desarrollar ciertas
enfermedades porque como humanos
alteramos su código genético y desde
entonces se han publicado muchos otros
proyectos investigaciones y experimentos
en donde humanos se están modificando
para poder cambiar ya estamos hablando
de que dejamos de ser biológicamente
diseñados ya existe el homo sapiens 2.0
no me acuerdo que decía ahí arriba pero
lo importante es cómo va a ser el
trabajo en el futuro
si nos vamos a convertir cada vez más en
super humanos entonces también significa
que vamos a estar cambiando nuestro
paradigma de trabajo
lo que sea que hemos hecho hasta hoy ya
no lo vamos a hacer en este futuro
entonces dejemos de pensar en que la
máquina nos va a reemplazar que dicha
que nos va a reemplazar afortunadamente
nos va a reemplazar porque esto
significa que como humanidad vamos a
potenciar nos al siguiente nivel
al nivel en donde los humanos podemos
ser
un servicio
o por lo menos ocuparnos como un
servicio y de esto es prueba el primer
unicornio colombiano llamado rap y ellos
iniciaron como un modelo muy similar al
de uber its y rápidamente emigraron a
convertirse en una empresa que estaba
con la misión de erradicar el desempleo
en colombia
cualquier cosa que usted pueda ofrecer
como servicio rápida en la plataforma
que lo puede emplear
y la verdad es que esto
cada vez más lo vamos a ver muchísimo
más frecuente se llama en la economía y
que básicamente significa que son
servicios bajo demanda basados en
proyectos que se puede dar por cualquier
persona y como estos hay bastantes
empresas que ya lo están ofreciendo uber
leaf más graves work allá en la esquina
a porque es un ejemplo interesantísimo
es una plataforma que emplea a cualquier
cantidad de miles de personas y ahí
pueden contratar los servicios una de
las personas en nuestro equipo de
desarrollo lo contratamos a partir de
work y estaba trabajando en otro
continente la comunicación y el proceso
de la logística fue absolutamente
segura y fue bastante fluida qué es lo
que dice el ceo the work estefan castril
él siguió dice que enap work acaban de
remover el requerimiento de tener título
universitario para cualquier descripción
de trabajo si la educación universitaria
se convierte en algo inalcanzable para
muchas personas y muchas empresas
todavía siguen demandando subtítulos
universitarios no estamos dispuestos a
perpetuar este sistema que deja a las
personas más vulnerables fuera del
sistema
qué va a pasar con las universidades y
las empresas dejan de requerir título
universitario para muchas profesiones
tal vez no para todos pero para muchos
hay bastantes estudiantes acá tal vez su
plan lineal era matricularse en la
universidad no quiero arruinarlo ni que
me culpen a mí desde la que les dijo que
no es de patrick olarán simplemente
piensen en la posibilidad de que un
pedazo de papel no les va a garantizar
tener empleo
amazon está ofreciendo 10.000 dólares a
sus empleados para que renuncien y se
conviertan en emprendedores
el 40 por ciento de la fuerza laboral en
eeuu ya trabaja en la economía
entonces lo que sea que hemos hecho
hasta hoy va a requerir otras
capacidades en el futuro
y estas capacidades son empatía
el poder identificar qué está sucediendo
a mi alrededor y cambiar mi toma de
decisión basado en otro
la comunicación
el pensamiento crítico
la creatividad algunas personas dicen
que eso es irreemplazable que las
máquinas nunca lo podrán hacer por
supuesto que lo pueden hacer
es ciencia son datos cualquier cosa que
sea ciencia y datos se puede descifrar
pero la creatividad viene la invención
y lo más importante como seres humanos
es mantener nuestra capacidad de
invención la experimentación
la curiosidad el emprendimiento
la inteligencia emocional y finalmente
como se mencionó esta mañana el aprender
a desaprender son las nueve habilidades
esenciales no son blandas no son
solamente estratégicas son esenciales
para el futuro del trabajo
veamos nuestro futuro
ahí decía futuro tachado hoy abajo
entonces ya no es el futuro lo que sea
que tengamos que hacer lo tenemos que
hacer hoy y consideremos que lo que sea
que vayamos a enfrentarnos a partir de
este punto a partir del año 2019 van a
ser como olas y las estamos surfeando
vamos a pasar mucho tiempo entrenando
nos practicando y preparándonos para
esas olas
todo para tres y si somos afortunados
cinco segundos encima de esa tabla
esto es una colonia de pingüinos haredit
en la antártica están siendo
tremendamente impactados por el cambio
climático
y esta es mi nueva ola yo he pasado en
negocios y emprendimiento mucho tiempo
he trabajado con inteligencia artificial
y tecnología por la mayoría de ese
tiempo y a partir de este año tomé la
decisión de encontrar una nueva ola y me
estoy enfocando a que el trabajo que
hago yo y que hace mi empresa vaya a
hacer para revertir los efectos del
cambio climático
no soy científica no sé nada de cambio
climático
pero esta buena ola en la que me voy a
la que me voy a enfrentar me va a dar
nuevas habilidades y me va a permitir un
futuro que yo no había planeado
ojalá que esos tres segundos encima de
esa tabla valgan la pena y el impacto
que vayamos a tener por esta decisión
arriesgada vaya también a ser
exponencial
muchas gracias por escucharme el día de
hoy pueden buscarnos como 'the next
impact o 10x impact en cualquier redes
social
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]